le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que
le programme de la journée du ministre
de l'industrie n'aura pas été de tout
repos
visite des usines dassault d'argonay en
compagnie de olivier serge dassault puis
passage à la mairie d'annecy le vieux
rencontrer les élus locaux au cours d'un
bref discours franck borotra a rendu
hommage à l'action menée par la
municipalité ans ils viennent dans le
domaine économique
le ministre a ensuite pris le chemin du
parc des glaisins afin d'inaugurer le
nouveau site industriel de l'usiné
metrix l'entreprise est spécialisée dans
les instruments de mesure multi mais
aussi aux copé autre vient tout juste de
s'installer à annecy le vieux
elle est opérationnelle depuis dix jours
franck borotra en a profité pour
souligner le savoir faire et la
compétitivité des entreprises implantées
en haute-savoie des entreprises de
taille moyenne qui innovent et
réussissent ce matin j'ai visité
l'entreprise dassault metrix voilà deux
exemples et volt de modèle pour le
développement en russie
le ministre a salué le fait que mes
tricks et dassault ont chacune à leur
manière réussi à mener à bien leurs
projets industriels et maintenu leur
confiance aux salariés français et
haut-savoyards une résistance
délocalisation pourtant rendu souvent
difficile par l'extrême concurrence
mondiale dans les domaines de pointe
l'occasion aussi pour le ministre de
répéter la nécessaire mobilisation de
l'europe dans ce domaine
je plaide pour une stratégie
industrielle de l'europe
ça n'est pas chose aisée il faut se
battre à la fois contre des
ultralibéraux à l'intérieur de l'europe
et contre une administration européenne
qui a une vue parfois dogmatique de la
concurrence parce que c'est l'intérêt de
la france et que c'est l'intérêt de
l'europe et je cesserai pas de le dire